blackwater's been in the news a lot
lately you're probably familiar with
them they're the private
security contracting firm that works in
iraq protecting diplomats and
ambassadors primarily for the state
department
the company formerly known as blackwater
will always be linked to the first
decade of the so-called war on terror
and it should
because it made billions of dollars off
it the invasion of iraq was a gravy
train for blackwater
the state department contracted it to
guard american officials around iraq
but soon allegations began surfacing
that put the company in the spotlight
blackwater founder eric prince has been
accused of overseeing
war crimes at his private security firm
during the iraq war
the bush administration has deployed a
shadow army of some 100 000 contractors
but the reality is that blackwater has
become a prime player in the war on
terror
nothing short of the bush
administration's praetorian guard
blackwater usa has become one of the
most powerful private actors in the
so-called war on terror
their operations are shrouded in secrecy
and people in congress find it almost
impossible to get information about
blackwater and other companies
operations
if you google the name blackwater you're
gonna come across scandal
after scandal after hit piece after hit
piece
blackwater was the most controversial
private military contractor or pmc
during the first decade of the war on
terror what some might call a private
army mercenaries profiting often the
second most expensive war in history
by the end of it all they brought in
over a billion dollars in government
contracts
blackwater was founded by a former navy
seal named eric prince
who the media likes to refer to as a
right-wing christian conservative
bankroller of president bush and his
allies
and blackwater envisions itself as the
fedex of the national security apparatus
a company founded by a right-wing former
navy seal eric prince who made a lot of
money providing mercenaries to the u.s
government but putting aside politics
for this video
i just referred to him as a war
entrepreneur in 2007
blackwater security contractors were
involved in a deadly shootout after that
the us government politicians the media
and the public all turned against
blackwater
calling them war profiteers killers war
criminals bullies without oversights
a modern-day merchant of death and
within a few years time
blackwater was no more but here's one
thing i learned from peter thiel
the billionaire co-founder of paypal
it's that if everyone is on the same
side of an issue
whether that be silicon valley all
leaning left or that blackwater and all
mercenaries are pure evil
there's probably a compelling argument
on the other side that gets drowned out
when people are unanimously on one side
that tells you not that they've all
figured out the truth but that they're
in a sort of totalitarian place that
they're in a one-party state where
they're not allowed to have dissenting
views i think somehow silicon valley
shifted from being
you know um quite liberal to uh being a
one-party state and those are those are
two very different things
according to its founder eric prince the
story of blackwater is a story of men
taking bullets to protect the men who
take out the credit
a tale of patriots whose names became
known only when lawyers and politicians
needed to blame somebody for something
and if you know anything about
politicians that sounds
exactly like something they would do so
was blackwater a group of patriotic
heroes
or just a bunch of trigger-happy war
profiteers
this is the rise and fall of the world's
most powerful private army
who blackwater really is who are these
guys these hired guns mercenaries
who taxpayers have paid more than a
billion dollars to since 2003 to protect
people
abroad is he getting favors from
political friends we'll look at that
tonight
the butch administration came to power
with a radical privatization agenda
their injuries don't get calculated
either their crimes don't get punished
what you have is a revolving door
blackwater and other companies benefit
the bush administration
and in turn the bush administration and
its republican allies in congress
have shielded these military contractors
from any effective oversight
if you're gonna be a war entrepreneur or
any kind of businessman for that matter
one overlooked aspect to business is
staying healthy the healthier you are
the smarter decisions you can make
the smarter decisions you make the more
money you make health is something i
take very seriously which is why magic
spoon is sponsoring today's video
this channel's favorite healthy cereal
that tastes too good to be true
it's got zero grams of sugar 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb gmo free and the
best part is that it still tastes just
like all the name brand unhealthy cereal
you grew up eating
this is a lot better than i remembered
my favorite flavors are cocoa chocolate
fruity loose fruit and cinnamon and
their fan favorite flavor of blueberry
is making a long anticipated return
after being sold out go to
magicspoon.comtrend to grab a variety
pack and try it today
and be sure to use promo code jake tran
at checkout to get 5
off your order now in the us and canada
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product that is backed by 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
whatever reason
the refund your money no questions asked
that's magicspoon.com
jaketran
black water started as an idea while
eric prince was a navy seal during the
90s
the soviet union had just fell marking
the end of the cold war
repeating once again our top story
soviet president mikhail gorbachev has
been removed from power
and there are tanks now in the streets
of moscow which also men
enter the giant piles of money the us
government was spending on the military
the end of the soviet union also marked
the start of the yugoslav wars
that led to some very graphic war crimes
that would definitely get this channel
to monetize if we elaborated on it
things that some navy seals thought
could have been avoided if the us kept a
modest peacekeeping force there
made up of u.s special forces soldiers
the problem was where would they train
even the navy seals america's most elite
special forces unit that should always
be training had a hard time finding
places to practice
the budget cuts were so extreme that
soldiers from different military
branches
basically stacked themselves on top of
one another at shooting ranges
so eric prince thought well if you want
to be a pilot you go to flight school
but if you wanted elite military
training there wasn't a place for that
so the idea of blackwater was born a
combination of a shooting range plus a
country club for special forces soldiers
and in 1997 blackwater was born in north
carolina
named after the black swamp water they
encountered on the land it ended up
being
the largest shooting facility in the us
with 400 thousand dollars in revenue
during the first year
and that's all it was they never thought
that they would ever send men overseas
as private military contractors
but then 9 11 happened
after the towers fell conversation
started about how to strike back and how
blackwater could help
the retaliation plan conceived was
called operation enduring freedom
the problem was there were some
important officials with
nasty reputations that the cia needed in
afghanistan
but the cia couldn't contact these messy
individuals themselves because it
wouldn't look good on them if the public
ever got one of it
however blackwater didn't have any of
these political restrictions
so they set the cia up with some of the
most useful men
in afghanistan blackwater received no
money from opening up their rolodex to
the cia
and eric prince said this move wasn't
ever conceived as a business decision
but this really showed the caa how
private businesses could help the
government's military and intel services
and they knew blackwater wanted to help
and soon the cia offered blackwater a
way just to do that
the cia was putting up bases all over
afghanistan but they didn't have the
manpower to provide security to all
those bases
so the cia offered a contract to guard
the bases to post security
which basically entails standing at the
gates and investigating the vehicles
that pulled up
and because blackwater's training
customers were all former special forces
guys with the right experience that
wanted to help
blackwater won their first contract in
the middle east this would be the humble
start to the meteoric rise of blackwater
[Music]
that u.s warships and planes launched
the opening salvo
of operation iraqi freedom
[Music]
the us invades iraq the iraqi government
collapses
the u.s left forces occupy most of the
country saddam hussein is nowhere to be
found
and his statue is toppled
and then comes a man named paul bremmer
he was appointed a position called the
coalition provisional authority
or cpa in charge of rebuilding iraq
basically he was the new temporary
leader or dictator from the other side's
point of view
of iraq and with the stroke of a pen
bremer became the most powerful man in
all of iraq
which also meant that he was the most
hunted man in iraq according to bremer
the u.s secret service had done a survey
on my security
and had concluded that i was the most
threatened american official anywhere in
the world
[Music]
the pentagon's protective services were
stretched then so who did they award the
21.3 million dollar contract to protect
the ambassador to
blackwater blackwater started with a
36-man team three small helicopters
paying each pmc 600
per day or 18 dollars per month or two
hundred sixteen thousand dollars per
year
or basically four times the pay of the
average special forces salary
brentwood was so hated that insurgents
reportedly offered thirty thousand
dollars from the body of a black water
guard
and in the end blackwater kept grammar
safe and no one was injured during the
11 month assignments
and with that sort of track record
blackwater was soon guarding everyone
basically any official that had a
potential target on their back was
guarded by blackwater pmcs
by mid-2004 they were doing security
contracts for the dod state department
and the cia
all over the world and were becoming
well known in dc
and their menacing bear pod logo started
showing up all over iraq
even being worn by iraqi civilians
in the mountains near pakistan soldiers
were caught in a days long firefight and
were almost out of ammo
the problem was the military couldn't
send a resupply mission because the drop
zone was too risky
so they asked blackwater and in an
instant without any bureaucracy a
blackwater plane packed with ammo headed
for the mountains to resupply the troops
free of charge
after a few more of those missions the
pentagon offered blackwater a 34.8
million
deal to make it official their biggest
contract yet
worth more than all their previous ones
combined and this story really
demonstrates blackwater's business model
in war the military needs things done
quickly as a matter of life and death
but sometimes their hands are tied
because of bureaucracy that's where pmcs
come in
they're supposed to offer more efficient
service whether that be security
construction
food services at a cheaper price
most of the time it doesn't end up being
all that cheaper watch this video to
learn more but that's the idea
as eric prince put it blackwater i
figured could be the fedex to the dod's
postal service
we didn't want to replace the military
we just wanted to make it more efficient
and help patch up the inevitable
logistical gaps that cropped up in the
pentagon planning
the approach benefited the pentagon and
it benefited our bottom line
and after that resupply contract money
started coming in from all directions
the shooting range in north carolina was
in full swing and massively expanded
they expanded into all sorts of
contracts all over the world they opened
offices and different subsidiaries and
affiliates all over the world
and in 2003 to 2004 the business grew
400
at the same time government contract
spending skyrocketed by 2005 it was
estimated that every 40 cents the us
government spent
was spent on contracts with private
companies with the biggest spenders
being the dod and the state department
but blackwater would soon learn the
downside of having so much of your
business rely on just one giant customer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
overnight blackwater became the most
hated name in america
four of the pmcs in the incident were
charged and later convicted
the government and the media went after
them from every possible angle including
the irs
lawsuits went flying and the end seemed
inevitable with the blackwater name and
logo blasted on the news 24 7
they decided to rebrand the company as z
surfaces which literally means nothing
z is a symbol for the element xenon an
invisible gas meant to represent their
new low profile
by 2009 eric prince stepped down as ceo
from the company he spent 12 years
building
and in 2010 he put the company up for
sale it was now valued less than it was
six years ago in 2004.
it was bought by a group of investors
and was then renamed once more to
academy
then eric prince and his family moved to
abu dhabi where he still is today
this just goes to show that if the
government can make you rich you can bet
that they have the power to take it all
away in a moment's notice
in the end even with all the controversy
no one under the security of blackwater
lost their life or suffered a serious
injury
private security is expected to grow up
to 81 billion dollars by 2023
and that's just in the us but what's the
verdict on it
well if we're gonna go to war whether or
not we should is a topic for another
video
but if we are going to war much like we
saw earlier with the war on terror
waging war requires huge numbers of
personnel that our volunteer military
just doesn't have
so if we're gonna go to war which has
been the norm throughout human history
you only have two choices have a
mandatory draft like during vietnam
or hire private military contractors so
the question becomes
would you rather have a draft where you
or your friend or your family gets sent
to war by force
or would you rather have the government
outsource these roles to train
professionals that want to do the job
personally i would choose the latter let
me know your choice in the comments
below
what's the state of the private military
world today it's huge
it's growing and it's very much active
but that will have to wait for a future
video
subscribe so you don't miss out
but war endures before man was
war waited for him as long as man is
war will always be always
if you enjoy more touchy videos like
these ones you are going to love
magic spoon because not only do they
help make videos like this possible
their product is actually amazing
seriously they're ridiculously easy to
work with and i really like them
today we're gonna try blueberry which is
now back in stock and as always we're
gonna continue our tradition of some
good old cereal asmr
you can really smell it when you open
the box
as always cereal first
man that is a strong smell in a good way
[Music]
this is a lot better than i remembered
so if you want to get your own variety
pack you can go to magicspoon.com
jake tran with the link below and use
coupon code jit trend to get five
dollars off your order
now shipping in the us and canada they
have a 100 happiness guarantee so you
have nothing to worry about and yeah
link below
if you are new here we make video essays
just like this one every single week
on the most provocative stuff in the
world of business going from war like
this one to
power to money to business all the above
everything that no one else talks about
so click that red subscribe button and
the bell notifications get notified when
new videos come out
we are almost at half a million
subscribers and when we get there i will
be doing a q a on my instagram at
jtrend.io
it's only going to be on my instagram so
you follow me there so you don't miss
out we have a ton of fun over there too
i post
lots of memes over there it's good and
behind the scenes stuff and daytona live
kind of stuff all that great stuff
over at jtrend.io that is gonna wrap it
up for this video i'm gonna finish the
serial
and i will see you guys in the next one
stay dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
foreign